The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, the next part,
today's going to be about
concurrent programming.
So in this lecture we are going
to study concurrent
programing with the emphasis for
correctness of programs.
Because parallel programs
will have the
same correctness issues.
So, if you want to get parallel,
you'd better get the
concurrency right first.
What we're also going do is
start with a much simpler
machine model.
In a program where we are going
to use Java, because I
think a lot of people
understand Java.
Also, we are going to do
some very simple shared
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
machine abstraction.
I'm not going to even talk about
any machine anymore.
I'm just going to talk about
concurrent programming here.
You need to get through this
one before you can start to
dig in deep into
the next level.
So in the next lecture, we will
switch from Java to C-C ,
I guess using MPI primitives
in here.
We'll start moving into
parallelism with emphasis on
performance.
And, of course, you have to get
correctness, that's given,
but we'll start looking at
performance in there.
And we'll start using the
distributive memory machine,
all the notions and details of
Cell, so we'll just kind of go
down and down in
that direction.
So, what's concurrency?
Sequential program
is -- because
sequential program opposite.
It's basically single
thread of execution,
with is a good one.
Finish that, go to the
next, go to the next.
That's a very simple abstract
model that for about 35 years,
40 years, none of the machines
were actually following, that
they had things in the back
that actually had some
parallelism.
A concurrent program is the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
because it's a collection of
autonomous sequential threads
executing logically
in parallel.
So you can execute this thing
either multi-programming, so
we can multiplex different
parts on multiprocessing.
Well, multiprocessing basically
has [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
starting on different
machines.
You can distribute, you
can actually send it
to different places.
Of course, you have to deal
with memory issues.
So, concurrency's not only
parallel systems. So you can
do interleaved concurrency.
You can have logically parallel,
but you run Thread A
for a while, contacts with
Thread B for a while, contacts
with Thread C, so you can have
multiple threads on the same
machine running.
Or you can actually have
running parallel.
You can have three different
machines running, A, B and C
all the time.
So you can have both in there.
But logically you should not
see a difference except for
performance and stuff
like that.
So what I'm going to do is
do a bunch of examples.
Can you read this?
Let's start with a bank.
So you have a bank account.
So in Java you just basically
have ID, password, and
balance, and you have some
way to construct
this object in here.
And you can ask, and see the
password is correct.
You can get the balance.
And you can post the balance.
So that's a very simple
account object.
If you have a bank, you have a
bunch of accounts in a hash
map, and you create the
hash map in here.
Then you can basically
[? figure out ?]
the bank, you actually create
a bank in here, and you can
get an account, given an ID.
Now, assume you want
to build an ATM.
How do you build an ATM?
So, you have a bank -- you
need a bank in here, and
here's some input and output
streams in here.
When you start the ATM, you will
set up these input and
output streams in here.
In the main function, what
you'll do is, you get a bank,
create where the input streams
are coming from.
Create output goes standard --
system output goes there.
And create an ATM in here, and
you will make the ATM run.
So how do you run the ATM?
So, what happens in run
is, you run forever?
ATM doesn't stop any time.
What you can do is you can ask
when somebody walks into the
ATM, you can say what's
the account ID.
Type the account ID.
You can get that account, so
of course, if the account
already is wrong it says,
throw exception.
You can say OK, what's the
password, get the password.
You take the password, if it's
wrong you throw exception.
Then you can say, here's
your balance today.
What do you want to do?
If you want to withdraw
or deposit.
If you want to withdraw you can
do a minus number, if you
want to deposit it will
be a plus number.
Then you can post that
into your balance.
Everybody got the
thing for ATMs?
So, assume activity trace.
So somebody comes and gives the
account ID, at least gives
the password, and say that they
have $100,000 and say how
much you withdraw,
$200 withdraw.
And you get the balance
in here.
Looks nice.
It works.
So I need to run multiple ATMs.
Assume I am in a place
that I actually want to put two
ATMs or four ATMs next to
each other.
So how am I going to do that?
So, in order to do that, there's
concurrency in Java.
So one way to get Java
concurrency is you can extend
this class thread and
define a method run.
Or you have interface called
[? Runabout, ?]
that you can basically use
that interface and has
estimated run.
Then when you have made
that run and when
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
start, that will get started.
Very simple way to do that.
Let me give you an example.
Little bit of a digression.
Why do you want concurrent
programming?
A lot of times, natural
application structure is not
sequential.
The world is not sequential.
And then try to sequentialize
the world sometimes means it's
much more complicated
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So sometimes it's natural to
do things in parallel.
A lot of times the
sequentiality's an artifact of
the programming language,
because we use a
language like that.
Sometimes doing things in
parallel ways, you can really
improve things like throughput
and responsiveness.
If you are doing IO, if you're
doing sequential programming
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
you're just twiddling your
thumb waiting for
the IO to come back.
In parallel things actually, you
can do parallel IO and you
can do a lot cool
stuff in here.
Of course, in this class,
if you are multicore and
multiprocessor multicore, you
can get parallel executions.
So there are more than one
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
Also, if you are building a very
large distributed system,
concurrent programming is, you
had to deal with, especially
dealing with things like
client-server type of
applications.
So here's our original ATMs. So
to go to multiple ATMs, I
am doing a few changes.
I'll go back and forth
a few times.
So the first thing I have done
is I have sett here number of
ATMs to be four.
Can you really read it
from back there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
Then what I have done is, in
here, I did four ATMs here,
and then I put it in a loop to
create this ATM, so I created
four ATMs in here and start
four ATMs, basically.
Then of course I extended these
ATMs so now we will
extend [? up a thread. ?]
And I haven't started that.
And the ATMs [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
ATMs, so it's great.
So now what happens is I assume
now there's two guys
going, both ATMs, at least
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] been.
Then enter the account and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE],
that's works really well.
No problem.
So we have two ATMs, two people
actually went on parallel.
One then deposited some money,
other one took money, great.
Now, as MIT students, they
want to do something,
they can hack it.
So, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
basically [UNINTELLIGIBLE] went
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], and
basically what
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
enter the password, and they
said I want to get $100.
I would get $90, basically.
So he had $100 in his account.
Then what he got was, so he
actually managed to get $180
out of an account
that had $100.
This is not a good ATM, at
least from the bank's
perspective.
So what went wrong?
If you look at what happened in
activity trace, so we print
100 in here.
And then you said, you want to
read this value, you both
entered 90, right here.
And this account balance
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
because the account
balance was 100.
You saw also the
account balance
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE], yes,
it is [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Then each went post, it went to
10 -- this also did a post
of the same time, result
came both 10.
How could this happen?
So that way it can happen
is, so in the ATM, the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE], what
happens is v is minus 90, and
this post [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
also when you start a
v it's minus 90.
Then you treat the
balance as 100.
So in this interleaving, and so
it is the plus, you get 10.
Also, before you write it out,
you read the balance in the
other interleaving, you've got
the balance as 100, and you do
the plus as 10.
So it destroyed the balance,
now balance became 10, and
also this guy also wrote the
balance -- it doesn't matter,
it got 10 updated twice,
and that's it.
So you can have interleaving
in here, that actually did
something that's not a
signature program.
And you're in big trouble.
So in order to get out of
that, problem is all
interleaving of threads are not
acceptable and current.
What you want is some kind
of a sequential-looking
performance, even though you'd
get parallel, you don't want
to do all these interleavings
in here.
So in order to do that,
Java provides this
synchronization mechanism.
That's just strict
interleaving.
So, what synchronizations do
is, they ensure safety for
shared updates.
So if you're sharing
something, so it
avoids races, basically.
It avoids this old interleaving
ordering here.
Also, it allows you to
coordinate actions among
shared space, basically.
Because at some point people
have to coordinate and take
that parallel computation.
With notification
you can do that.
So, when multiple threads access
the shared resource,
simultaneously, it's safe only
if all accesses have no effect
on the resource.
Basically, we're reading
variables.
But everybody can read the same
variable, because you're
not changing anything.
I can do that.
Or all accesses are
idempotent.
So you can say, we
can do that.
Or only one access at a time.
Which is called mutual
exclusion.
So in this case we are
changing something.
It's not that important.
So we have to actually
do mutual exclusion.
So here's a way to look at
safety problems. Here might be
an algorithm that you and your
roommate have. So you arrive
home, look in the
fridge, no milk.
Leave for grocery, arrive
at grocery, buy milk
and arrive at home.
The minute you leave for
grocery, your roommate arrives
and do this.
Then what do you have is
you have too much milk.
So here's the problem
in a little bit
more abstract sense.
And you need a way to
synchronize this.
So how about this.
No milk and no note.
So you leave a note before you
actually leave the house and
buy milk, and then you come
back and remove the note.
Does this work?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: I mean here
also you can do that,
no milk and no note.
So both are started.
We would leave a note,
and these things can
happen at the same time.
There's a little bit of things
saying OK, why didn't you see
your roommate.
They go buy milk, he goes
to buy milk and you have
too much milk too.
So the way to do this
in Java is this
notion of critical section.
Critical section is where only
one thread can be in it at a
given time.
The way you can do it with
Java is, you can put
synchronized in front
of the method.
And you do that method, only
one person can be executing
that method at any one time.
So in here I would say get
balance and post so you can
synchronize.
So when you do that,
what happens is --
so in here you read.
No problem, you can
do this parallel.
You can do this in parallel.
And then you say, first
take out post in here.
And this [? takes out ?] post.
Because of synchronization
these things can't have an
order, because this has to
happen in some order.
Either this happens first
and this has to
finish before this one.
At that point you can actually
-- what happened now?
Are we happy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
At least banks realize --
bank's book is correct.
Because it realizes,
here is more money.
But actually it let you
take more money than
your account had.
So at least it got
that value right.
But what happened was, why
is this happening now?
AUDIENCE: You want the
check covered.
PROFESSOR: OK, you want
to check also.
Good.
So the key thing is, here
we didn't check.
So you have a negative bank
balance happening.
So this is a problem
with atomacity.
Because synchronized
methods execute the
body at atomic units.
So when that happens, the entire
thing of body happens
without anybody else
[? modifying. ?]
That's the only thing that's
happening at any given time.
The code read [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
you chose is probably too
small in this case.
What we need to do is, we
need to basically have
synchronizing not on the
method but a lot more
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] in there,
so you have to do block
synchronization.
So synchronized keywords
actually work like this too.
You can say instead of doing
a method, you can just
synchronize account and all
those things happen
synchronously within
that block.
So, now what we have done
is we have built a
bigger atomic unit.
So here's the programming
here.
So here's the synchronized
unit in here.
So what we did was, we say
instead of these synchronized
and these synchronize
separately, both of these
computations have to
happen atomically.
So when I check our
bank balance, we
can't do anything else.
So now what happens?
So yeah, in this situation
you're reading, reading, and
you get synchronized account
in here, and I do account
balance plus [? well ?]
and post the account.
So in here I go to
10, I do that.
If I start the other one here,
I have to wait till that
entire synchronization is
over before I do that.
Of course, I don't have enough
balance, so I throw exception.
Are we still happy?
Is there issue on this one?
I mean, I guess -- assume you
can do something clever, but I
haven't done that.
But there's one issue in here.
Which, when you start it's
just, balance is 100.
So in this one, say
balance is 100.
You go type it and then voila,
you type it and then, sorry, I
don't have money.
So that's not nice, because if
you've got the balance you
should be able to get that.
So how we deal with that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: So that's probably
the best solution to that
because we can only
log into one.
But in this example I assume
what we are doing.
How can we deal with this one?
AUDIENCE: There are two
ways of doing it.
One is to put the whole thing
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE] section.
The other way is to notify
somebody that the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR:
So what I can do is I can
say OK, wait a minute.
I am actually going to
make the critical
section even bigger.
So now I print the balance
before I do that.
So the entire thing is
critical section.
I print the balance off
and then go ahead
and withdraw that.
So what might happen
in this case?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's the issue of a little
bit of waiting.
So what happens is, in here.
You do this one, and you do
synchronized account.
And you put the balance and
other one do synchronized and
you ask the question.
In here.
And you start thinking.
We can start thinking that my
machine is not responsive,
it's just waiting for the
critical section started.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] and you
have this [? IOUN ?]
sitting in the middle.
That's not good either.
So he has a performance issue.
So that's not a good
way of doing that.
So you don't get any
response in here.
So you can make this
atomic [? radius ?]
but there's a price you'll
pay by making it
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] large.
So here's another thing
we want to do.
I want to do something that can
transfer account balance
from one account to another.
So I might do that if I have a
method in here to transfer
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
account, this amount.
So what I do is, I synchronize
from account.
I say, I get balance in here.
If the balance is available,
I can synchronize the two
accounts and force it there.
See any problems?
So let's see what happenes.
So assume I want to transfer
10 to Ben's account and Ben
wants to transfer 20 to
Alyssa's account.
So what happens is,
this goes --
get the value in here, and
you synchronize to
two and say OK, great.
Now what happens is, in here,
in from, I am holding a
Alyssa's account.
There I am holding
Ben's account.
Now, inside I want to
synchronize for Alyssa.
And I'm still [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
when I --
wait until Alyssa
got released.
And he says I want to wait
till Ben got released.
And nobody's going to release,
and you're hung.
You are in what you call
a deadlock situation.
That's a deadlock.
So you have to be very careful
when you do synchronizing.
If you do multiple
synchronization, the easiest
thing you can do is, you
do it in some order.
And end up in a a deadlock
situation.
This is a very common way of
parallel programs doing that.
So how to avoid deadlock?
Because deadlock is, there's
a cycle in locking graph.
So somebody's going to lock
somebody, he's going to lock
that person, and we
have a cycle.
You can end up in deadlock
situation.
So standard solution for that
is, you take locks in some
kind of canonical order.
You don't take in
arbitary order.
So it's some kind of a -- you
have some base in, OK, if you
are taking this lock, you have
to have, after that, you can
take a higher order lock.
So you have to have some
kind of order in here.
Acquire in increasing
order and release
in decreasing order.
So you have some kind
of force in here.
This ensures deadlock freedom
most of the time, but it's not
that easy to do a
lot of the time.
Because your program might not
fit into this nice ordering a
lot of times, and then sometimes
you realize that you
had locked something and at that
time it's too late when
you realize it.
And then it has a
different order.
So this is, you have to sometime
do some changes to
basically make the program
work like this.
So in here, what you can do
is, in the program you can
associate some kind of a rank,
and when you put in account,
you put the rank to the
account number.
So you have some kind
of ordering in here.
Then what you have is, you
always get the first, highest
rank one before you
go the next one.
So there's some ordering
in here.
So at least then we'll be at
least forced into some
ordering in here.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
deadlock [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Not statically.
Because most of the time that
means you have to know all the
possible control profile,
to do that.
And, for example, there are some
tools that can -- because
you might know that, for
example, assume you are trying
to enforce some ordering
of locks.
But it's not the software, it's
the locking software,
that doesn't know about those.
You can actually write a locking
software that will
tell you, like look, you are
trying to acquire locking out
of order, out of this
locking order.
Most of the time you might be
OK because it might not hit,
but [? we assume ?] that if
you are doing unsafe thing
that might work, so.
So you can put some dynamic
checks that might warn you
that you might be in a
situation, but it doesn't
guarantee you.
So deadlock is something, you
have to basically -- there's
no nice tools for.
Basically, it's almost a
software [? methodology. ?]
So, for example, you can impose
a software methodology
to say, I'm following this
convention and that will
guarantee me deadlock freedom.
So one good convention
is this, basically
some order in here.
So, another interesting thing
and hard thing is race
conditions.
These are non-deterministic
timing dependent, and cause
data corruption, crashes that
are impossible to detect.
So the problem with race
conditions is the minute you
put your debug, or put any
debugging things, race
conditions goes away.
It comes back when you are in
it all and you're debugging
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
It happens again because
it's basically
an independent thing.
In fact, I have this
interesting
experience with myself.
A long time ago I was working
at Microsoft and
I worked two summers.
In one summer I was working on
their LAN manager and network
manager, and there's a bug that
after you run the network
manager for some time
it just freezes.
That's not a nice behavior
to have if you are
running your network.
That bug lasted the
entire year.
And at the end they had,
I think, a $2,000
bounty on that bug.
Because the minute you do
any instrumentation, the
[? bug isn't ?]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
When you have more
instrumentation and have 100
machines running, heavily,
hitting another machine.
Once in a while voila.
It freezes.
And you have no idea
why it happened.
That was so hard to debug
because there's nothing you
could do, because any time
you do any changes,
the bug goes away.
You had to be very careful
because these things are not
easy to find, and happen
intermittently.
And very hard to debug.
So having good discipline and
good design really helps to
get rid of it.
These are not something you can
go through like program
debugs, it [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
cycle.
If you read that cycle, it's
a very slow cycle.
The best way to do that is get
the design right first.
So what's a data race?
So I assume I had this
program like that.
So I read [? hit ?] in there,
and then I modify
and write in this.
This doesn't have to be
in two statements.
If we [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
same statement, the compiler
might put it in register,
read, update and modify
and write.
So it might just look hits
equals hits plus 1 and hits
equals hits plus
1 on the cycle.
Doesn't have to
[? have temporary. ?]
and in your call.
Because the compiler puts a
[? temporary ?] in there.
And if you execute like
this you're happy.
But if you get excluded in this
order, I don't get at it
two times, I only get it because
I read hit the order
given values.
This adds once and writes.
And this also adds one to
[? the ordinary value ?]
and write.
So I only get it increased
by one and you
are in a bad situation.
The problems with data races
is this non-determinism.
We ensured [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that this mutual exclusion.
So if you have same data access,
make sure that they
are in the mutual
exclude region.
You can basically see that it
has access to old objects.
Before you go there, one
interesting thing is this is
just a problem with all parallel
programs. So at the
beginning you say OK, I'm going
to have this nice mutual
excluded, lock ordered
program.
You write this.
It worked correctly,
beautifully, but run dog slow
because now we are huge
critical sections.
Everybody's waiting in data and
then someone says I want
to run fast. I think I
don't need this lock.
It doesn't seem to be, so keep
removing locks, making
critical sections smaller
and stuff like that.
That's where all the problems
start cropping up, because all
this nice design goes
to the dogs when you
have performance issues.
So when you realize that, you
want to write this nice
program, nice large critical
sections, stuff like that.
The programs will
work correctly.
But run like a dog because now
it's sequential in many cases
because you are doing this.
Then you go and say OK, I
want to run parallel.
Eh, this is OK.
That's when problems
start creeping up.
So make sure that when you get
a discipline, as you can go
into the performance improvement
but you still
maintain at least some
part of discipline.
That's the hard thing.
So I want to switch gears a
little bit to talk about a
classic problem.
It's called dining philosophers
problem.
So, there are five philosophers
sitting around a table.
Between each of the
philosophers there's a chopstick.
So each philosopher
do two things.
He thinks -- he or she thinks
or he or she eats.
So the philosopher thinks
for a while.
And then the philosopher
is hungry.
She stops thinking and she
picks up a left and right
chopstick, eats, and puts
the chopsticks down.
He cannot eat until they have
both chopsticks right in hand
because you can't eat
with one chopstick.
So you have to wait until
you get both chopsticks.
When you are done, you put
the chopsticks down.
Then after you're done, you go
back to thinking again for a
while and come back to eating.
That's the classic problem.
So how to write that,
record that?
You can have philosopher
extend thread, and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
philosopher you have a chopstick
in here, and instead
of philosopher buy left
and right chopstick.
Then what you do is you create
a number of philosophers and
you get a new chopstick and
start to the left and you go
to the other philosophers
assigning left and right
chopsticks in here, and
then you start the
philosophers going.
So you just set up a chopstick
[? on it, ?]
and then you share the chopstick
and do that.
So here is what a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
philosopher does.
So I am here, I'm taking my left
chopstick, I'm taking my
right chopstick and I'm going to
eat and I'm done eating and
I'm putting down there.
What will happen in this one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: In what situation,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE],
but right
technical though is different.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: You end up in
a deadlock because
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
we will pick up the left
chopstick suddenly, and they
all try to take the
right chopstick.
There's no right chopstick and
nobody has right chopstick and
everybody waiting for somebody
to drop the chopstick, that's
not going to happen.
So you have a problem.
Second way to solve that is
this, and you say OK.
The problem is everybody
trying to
pick up this chopstick.
I will put unique variable
table, unique object table.
If anybody want to eat, I
need to own the table.
What will this do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
AUDIENCE: It prevents two people
who wouldn't normally
interact from eating
at the same table.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So what happens is only one
person can eat at a time.
Which works perfectly,
beautifully, sequential.
So, you wonder if one
philosopher eating, the person
or [? posit ?] can eat.
But you're not allowed
to because the
chopstick in there.
So one way of doing that is
sequentialized large regions,
with putting these critical
sections in there.
This works.
Not greatly, but it will work.
Another thing is, of course,
what I point out to have some
kind of ordering.
So you put some position
ordering and saying if you are
sitting in even position, you're
the first to pick the
left one, if you are putting
an odd position, you're
supposed to pick
the right one.
So in some sense, it got
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
go here, the person go here,
so only one can get that so
you don't have ordering.
At least between those two
you can maintain that.
So you can do something but you
have to figure out what
the right ordering in here.
This is not a linear
list, linear
ordering for this circuit.
But you can copy ordering and
say OK, look, if you do that
this new way, you can run into
a deadlock situation.
There are a lot of types of
synchronizations in Java, and
then tomorrow you learn
more different type of
synchronization with available
using [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE],
so using MPI.
But there are a lot of potential
problems you are
worried about.
Deadlock you have
to worry about.
Two or more threads stop, wait
for each other forever.
Livelock.
What livelock means is two or
more threads basically trying
to do something but never
made progress.
So good example.
So assume I go -- it's like
sometimes you try to cross
each other on the road and you
go into them and say oops, or
you both say oops, sorry,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
You get into a situation that
you try to go something, both
you start to move a little bit
and then do that and you keep
doing that forever and ever,
doing it, right.
So that can happen.
If you program right, you can
actually try to avoid deadlock
by doing that, but both no one
making forward progress, so
that's called livelock.
So another thing that's
called starvation.
So the ordering is a
very good example.
So ordering says the higher
order guy always gets the lock
for the lower guy.
So assume you have thousands
of things and everybody's
trying to do something.
If you have an lower number,
you probably never get to
around to get picked up because
always if higher order
person has, that person
will get the lock.
So if they're ordering
constraint in there, you can
be in situation that some people
always get and others
never get -- there's no fairness
in that, because when
you some ordering constraints.
So again, lack of fairness.
Of course, race conditions.
So you didn't realize that the
same object is accessed by
multiple people without being
in a particular section.
That's the key --
I mean don't try to do fancy
things by letting multiple
people have access
to same thing.
This is not much of issue on
distributed memory machines
because there's only you
access to your memory.
But the problem there is if you
keep values, you suddenly
start giving it to everybody and
say go play, assuming that
only one person have
access to it.
So multiple people might be
modifying it and then what are
you going to do.
So that issue is there.
So when you are doing, using
data, you got to be very
careful who holds it
and at what time.
So, concurrency and parallelism
are important
concepts in comparison beyond
what we are doing in here.
Concurrency can simplify
programming beyond anything.
It's very hard to understand and
debug concurrent programs.
That's the entire reason that we
are still doing sequential
programming and this is entire
reason that multiple people
are looking at it in a very --
people are scared because
writing and getting concurrent
program right is probably an
order of magnitude harder than
trying to get sequential
programs right.
This is issue.
Parallelism is critical
for high performance.
I mean, it was huge for
supercomputers in national
labs and now it's becoming
everybody's
issue because of multicore.
Basically, you need to
understand concurrent and
concurrence issues, it's the
basis of writing parallel
programs. So, you will run
into all these issues,
deadlock, you can deadlock on
limited access on Cell, you
can deadlock on messages.
So everybody is waiting for
somebody else to send you a
message and nobody's sending a
message because that other guy
will send you a message.
You can [? easier ?]
do that in a message in there,
and a lot of times you can
deadlock in that.
So this lecture we kind of did
concurrent programming, how to
write a concurrent program.
We are going to switch gears
and start going into
parallelism next.
But keep these issues in my
mind when you are writing
parallel programs. Have things
like 617 we had very good
discipline on testing and
methodology of development.
You probably won't have kind
of discipline on how to do
parallelism.
So there are many ways --
next few lectures we'll cover
many different ways of doing
parallelism.
Parallelism's a very powerful
tool, but if you don't use it
in a disciplined way, you will
not be able to debug these
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I mean you run into bugs that
are so subtle, so difficult
it's very hard to find.
You don't want in
that situation.
So having a good design, good
disciplining programming will
actually get you working
correct program.
Good.
That's all I have for today.
You can spend some time
filling out this one.
Just put your name down
and you're done.